♪ You can't always get
what you want ♪
- C'est ici qu'ils devaient se
rassembler, mais Fierté Montréal
en a décidé autrement :
le traditionnel défilé de la
Fierté est annulé sans préavis.
- C'est la pière angulaire
de la semaine. Moi, ça me met
en colère. C'est surtout le fait
qu'on apprend ça le matin même.
- Près de 100 000 spectateurs
et 12 000 participants étaient
attendus après deux ans
d'absence. La déception est
vive.
- Bien je suis très déçu,
je suis un petit peu fâché.
- Des bénévoles, sans voix,
ont appris l'annulation comme
tout le monde.
RACHEL Rgestionnaire
prog. Expérience nat., Katimavik
- On a travaillé fort, pour...
On a juste une fois par année,
la fierté gaie. On aimerait
bien l'avoir à nous autres.
- C'est pourtant le manque de
ressources humaines qui auraient
forcé la mise au rancart
du défilé.
MACHE, directeur
général, Fierté Montréal
- C'est vraiment très triste.
On ne veut pas qu'on voie autre
chose là-dedans : c'est un
manque pur de ressources.
- 80 personnes manquaient
à l'appel pour assurer un défilé
sécuritaire, à en croire Fierté
Montréal.- Si c'est vraiment lae
raison, pour moi, c'est de
l'incompétence malheureusement.
- Je m'attendais pas
à ce qu'on annule la marche.
- Les organismes sont convaincus
qu'ils auraient pu trouver
des bras pour sauver les
célébrations, bien que les
bénévoles se fassent
de plus en plus rares.
CHRISTIAN TANGUAY, DG, Centre
communautaire LGBTQ+ de Montréal
- Il y a vraiment un défi depuis
la COVID d'avoir des bénévoles
soudés à la caus
es touristes venus
de Washington D.C.,
le défilé s'avérait la cerise
sur le sundae.
Un coup dur pour l'économie
du Village. Ce restaurateurvient
importante de son chiffre
d'affaires.
GEORGES PAPPAS, propriétaire
du Saloon bistro bar
- C'est dommage pour Montréal
parce que ça va faire un mauvais
goût. Parce que le monde qui
s'en vient d'ailleurs puis se
dise la "canceller".
Je sais pas.
- La Ville de Montréal,
partenaire de l'événement,
a aussi constaté l'annulation
le jour même et demandera des
comptes.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Si on avait été au courant
qu'il manquait des effectifs
même quoi que ce soit, on aurait
mis les énergies nécessaire.
Puis je pense que c'est ça
ma frustration ce matin.
- Avec ou sans défilé, la
communauté LGBT montréalaise
n'avait pas dit son dernier mot.
C'est finalement à l'initiative
d'organismes communautaires
qu'une marche a rassemblé plusds
la métropole.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Mon